you know if anybody ever said to me you
hit like a girl my first response would
be okay i want to find out how hard a
girl hits
[Music]
hey there folks something a little bit
different this time this is actually a
project that has been in the works for
several months it i've been at this for
a while i want to talk about the way
that female characters women
are depicted in action scenes in movies
and more specifically the way in which
they are shown when they are in action
scenes fighting against men now what got
my mind thinking about all this in the
first place was my partner liz and i
watched a little while back the third
season of cobra kai did a review of it
at the time i didn't really like the
third season of cobra kai very much and
amongst my issues was the character of
tori who i cannot stand i have a lot of
reasons for thinking she's a lousy
character but one of the many things i
don't like about her is the fact that it
is incredibly obvious that one of the
primary reasons she exists as a
character at all is to give sam daniel
larusso's daughter somebody to fight
whenever a big brawl breaks out because
they are always up against each other
sam is almost never put in direct
physical confrontation with a male
character in anything other than a
sparring scenario that started to really
bug me by the time the third season was
over i found myself wondering
is this a bigger problem
are women not allowed to fight men in
action settings and so i started to look
into it and i found out that no that's
not really the case but there is some
odd patterns that emerged as i dug into
this
all right let's talk about my sample
size and what i looked into i decided to
focus primarily on the superhero genre
now there's a couple reasons for this
the first is it's something i already
like so it's easier for me to go through
these movies and pay attention to them
than it might have been with other
genres the other thing is while there is
going to be a lot of marvel examples
because there's a lot of marvel movies
this is hardly going to be a single
studio project i'm going to be looking
at marvel movies dc movies including
ones from before the current dc
continuity so i'm going to be looking at
older batman movies i'm going to be
looking at blade i'm going to be looking
at x-men this is a pretty decent sample
size across decades worth of movies with
different directors some men some women
different producers different studios
behind them so
if there is
an agenda
by any one of these entities that should
not affect the output of the others so i
felt like this was a decent spread
as far as a sampling to get a idea of
the patterns in these situations the
other reason that i wanted to go with
superhero genres is the fact that i
would figure this would have the best
shot
at men and women fighting on an even
playing field because we're dealing with
superpowers you can power up a female
character as much as you want so there
really isn't the usual lame ass excuse
of well men are just naturally stronger
what do you want we're dealing with
fantastical worlds and superpowers that
shouldn't apply here
next up i need to do some definitions in
terms of what it was that i was looking
at and noting so i'm not doing every
single superhero movie that came out in
the last 20 plus years i am zeroing in
on ones that had noted female characters
in action scenes so we're gonna be
skipping a whole bunch of movies that
did exist but either didn't have these
scenes at all or they were such a minor
part of it it wasn't worth me going
through the whole movie to find so
here's some of the things i was looking
for were feminine characters put in
confrontation with masculine characters
directly at all
if so how did that fight go now the main
thing that i'm looking for here i am
looking for confrontations that feel
like fights between equals an even
footing
battle now granted even footing fair
fight it's a little bit subjective
especially when some superpowers come
into play because
you know the way that they impact the
fight it may unbalance it one way or
another but something that to my
subjective eye felt like a fair fight
and was meant to be presented as two
equals having it out i also should do a
clarification of what i mean by fight my
focus here is on hand to hand combat no
gun fights and
very lit there's gonna be a couple but
very little weapon battles because the
instant that a deadly weapon is
introduced it does change the dynamic of
the fight because in a hand-to-hand
fight i can basically kind of compare
how many times does she hit him
and in what ways and how many times does
he hit her and in what ways the minute
you bring in say swords whoever gets the
first stab in is probably going to win
or at the very least a single hit is
going to do a lot more damage regardless
of who delivers it simply because of the
presence of weapons as i said there are
going to be a couple of weapon fights in
here but not many i really wanted the
primary focus to be hand to hand and
finally there is a term i'm going to be
using a lot so i should define that and
that is badass but i'm not using badass
as a noun i'm using it as a verb so when
i say that a character is badassing
their opponents well what that means is
they are completely dominating them and
basically taking no damage now with
female characters in particular this
takes one of two forms the
far more common one is that they
basically do not get hit at all they
take out whoever they're against be a
one-on-one or against a group and the
female character just does not take a
hit
period the less common version of
badassing is that she does take some
hits but they basically have zero impact
on her so while technically she got hit
she might as well not have and that does
come into play with some of these uh
because we are dealing with superheroes
some of the real op characters and
finally one last thing i did not count
fights that were against
gender indeterminate things or monsters
so for example things like the chitari
in the avengers whatever the hell it was
thanos bulked out his army with in
infinity war and those weird multi-eyed
whatevers that the enchantress was
controlling a suicide squad if it's part
of a mindless horde or if it's a monster
that i can't tell what it's meant to be
that's not what i'm talking about i want
to deal with obvious man vs woman combat
or woman versus woman combat if that's
all the movie offers again we'll go over
the numbers after i go through all this
now i gotta start running through some
numbers because i watched 44 movies to
go through all this so let's get started
and let's start arbitrarily with the
thor franchise the first thor gives us
lady sif who takes on frost giants who
are definitely masculine coded and while
she does take one kick over the course
of that fight i would call this pretty
much a badassing the battle sort of
situation she also takes on the
destroyer but that's a robot so i'm not
gonna count it in the sequel sif
badasses her way through the opening
battle frigga manages to badass malakath
and is then restrained and taken down by
the super elf ragnarok hella basically
badasses everybody from the first big
fight she has one stab that gets
delivered on her but it doesn't faze her
at all she badasses thor and he does get
punches in but again they seem to have
zero impact the only thing he can hit
her with is lightning which doesn't
really feel like it's part of a normal
fight it's a random new superpower and
even that didn't really do much to her i
just hit her with the biggest lightning
blast in the history of lightning it did
nothing also in ragnarok we have
valkyrie badassing loki we look to the
iron man franchise we get the
introduction of black widow who just
badasses her way through a one-on-one
fight and then a group fight iron man 3
pepper potts gets some powers and then
badasses her way through some villains
winter soldier widow versus bucky widow
gets onto him delivers some hits and
then is thrown off doesn't really take a
punch over in civil war widow badass is
a bunch of thugs and then ultimately
gets tossed away by crossbones sharon
and widow take on bucky both of them are
tossed and then widow is lifted and
choked wanda badass's vision widow
badasses ant-man and then gets thrown
around widow versus clint is just a toss
around one throws one then the other
throws the other
you're pulling your punches and just for
a quick comparison if you're thinking
that's how most of the fights at the
airport went let's take a look at what
was going on between cap and spidey ah
oh
ow
okay yeah see those are hits
the first avengers also gave us natasha
versus clint and he does not land a
single clean hit on her plus she has
that whole badassing scene as her
introduction age of ultron while i would
consider ultron himself to be masculine
coated i am not counting the drones and
so that basically lives scarlet witch
getting one-shotted with a shock arrow
guardians gamora pretty much badasses
quill and while he does get the upper
hand it is never by outright hitting her
he never lands a punch she does later
get roughed up by drax but that's not
really a proper fight that's mostly a
grab and a choke she does absolutely
have a proper even match with nebula
black panther gives us what might be our
first noted case of a fair fight between
male and female characters now there is
badassing in the casino on the parts of
okoye and nakia but later on when the
dora melanche take on killmonger and
then when shuri and nakia take on
killmonger those are pretty evenly
matched fights although there is going
to be an asterisk on that
there's actually going to be an asterisk
on a number of these we'll circle back
to those at the end the original ant-man
i'm gonna gloss over because i don't
consider a sparring mash to really be a
proper fight but i guess i will note
that uh she kicks his butt ant-man 2
though when wasp properly gets to be a
superhero she badasses her way through
the restaurant goons now the ghost
versus wasp is fairly even and scott
gets in there and even gets a good kick
but there is gonna be an asterisk on
that fight as well
captain marvel we get what feels like a
fairly even match early on but that
again is a sparring match so that
doesn't feel like it has the same weight
she later badasses her way through a
scroll ship she takes a few hits but
they fail to slow her down even slightly
during the subway brawl she is fighting
a scroll but it's a scroll that is
looking like a woman so based strictly
off visuals i'm inclined to count that
as a woman versus woman fight later she
gets one shot on the scroll ship and
later on when her powers come on full
bore she just tears through everything
and is only briefly restrained and takes
a couple of hits that do not phase her
at all in other words badassing in
infinity war when two of thanos's goons
come for wanda and vision one male one
female one immediately breaks off to
take on proxima midnight while vision
takes on glaive now wanda does not glave
around a few times but she only ever
gets hit by proxima later widow does
badass glaive but that is also part of a
group effort and during that same group
effort proxima does take hits from
falcon later on gamora takes no hits
from thanos when she stabs him but it's
fake anyway so i'm disinclined to count
it but if i were it would have been a
badass during the actual fight she gets
grabbed by the neck and restrained
immediately now most of the climax is
against faceless monsters so i'm not
parsing any of that when nebula takes on
thanos she does get a number of hits in
but she takes only one hit and then goes
down and later on we have wanda akoy and
natasha taking on machines and monsters
and proxima midnight interesting that
the three female avengers take on the
primary female villain end game the
whole team badasses thanos later on we
have nebula and gamora badassing
faceless forces i'm just inclined to
really count widow versus hawkeye as
much of a fight but uh for the record
it's one throw a piece the nebula
showdown isn't a fight at all it's just
one shot fired wanda later badasses
thanos and is only stopped by a
bombardment there is later the big lady
avenger group thing but that's a pretty
unorganized melee and the only real
one-on-one that i caught out of that was
okoye one shot in glaive and when carol
danvers shows up to take on thanos she
hits the heck out of him he tosses her
around and then one shots her black
widow is pretty much all women v women
natasha versus elena being the big one
now the taskmaster fight is a woman
versus a woman but there's also an
asterisk on that one we're gonna come
back to it
shang chi because i saw this in the
theater i was not able to as carefully
document exactly who they were fighting
against but i did notice that out of the
three primary female characters who do
fight two of them take only one hit a
piece and in both cases that hit is an
open palm to the chest very gentle does
not take them down okay so that's the
mcu let's talk dc birds of prey as part
of an opening montage we have harley
roughing up a lady roller derby player
huntress taking down the gangsters takes
no damage although that is more of a gun
and projectiles fight so it's hard to
quantify with how i'm doing this harley
later gets tackled by montoya there's
the guy with the crowbar who gets killed
by the huntress before the fight even
starts the raid on the police station
has harley just badassing her way
through the entire bunch of cops dinah
later badasses some goons in the alley
but she does take one face and one gut
punch and she does seem to notice them
they don't really slow her down at all
so i'm still counting it as a badassing
but it's a little bit more than we've
seen so far we have harley badassing
inmates we have harley versus a whole
bunch of bikers it's pretty much all
badass she gets grabbed once and takes
two kicks to the chest and a brief choke
but yeah those don't last long and don't
impact her much when harley and montoya
go at it that's a pretty evenly matched
fight during the big climax fight
montoya gets tossed around and that's
about it pretty much the whole crew just
does a bunch of badassing i mean yes by
the very end hardly looks beaten up but
that has more to do with the fact that
she took a hard tumble on concrete
suicide squad hardly gets one shot at by
batman enchantress versus the group is
interesting because she takes more hits
than i have remembered her taken
including a flat out punch to the head
from deadshot so okay the entire group
still isn't really able to slow her down
much but that shot was interesting to
catch and of course later on it's harley
who gets to rip out her heart wonder
woman during the invasion of themyscira
the amazons only go down from gunfire
but in the hand to hand i did not see a
single amazon take a single hit the ally
fight no hits taken no man's land and
the dash to town afterwards no hits
taken diana assaults the base no hits
taken she's just badassing her way
through this although when she takes up
the wrote it up ludendorff there is a
brief but pretty legitimate brawl with
not only throws but also body hits the
confrontation with aries is a lot of
zapping magic nonsense around and when
they briefly go hand to hand it's
basically just a lot of throws wonder
woman 1984 she badasses her way through
the mall fight barbara later gets to
badass a guy in the street diana does
start getting slowed down later but it's
interesting that it's from bullets and
that would include the convoy chase and
the white house battle and both times
diana takes on barbara it is a pretty
legit brawl batman v superman dawn of
justice wonder woman only really fights
a monster granted it is based off a
masculine character so i suppose we
could count it she gets a car thrown at
her she blocks pretty much everything
thrown at her with the shield she does
take one punch but the shot where we see
it is from quite a distance
justice league theatrical version wonder
woman versus the terrorists she just
completely badasses them amazon versus
steph ben wolfe the pair of demons are
largely shooting lasers so there isn't
nearly as much hand to hand as you would
expect now steppenwolf is swinging an
axe around but in the theatrical we
don't see a lot of those hit slam we
just see him swinging and people flying
around but we don't actually see the
hits later on he does get a direct hit
on amazon on horseback but otherwise
he's largely slamming the ground sending
out shock waves and tossing people
around the big flashback is frankly it's
too much chaos i can't even with that
thing later on steppenwolf throws mero
around the first time the league takes
on steppenwolf wonder woman blocks
everything with the shield and just gets
tossed about a bit when superman takes
on the justice league wonder woman makes
use of the lasso but does get grabbed
and thrown and there's a quick back and
forth of head butting but she goes down
from that the big climax fight so far as
i was able to tell every single hit
directed at wonder woman is blocked by
the shield or the bracers she does
sometimes get knocked back from the
force of that but she blocks them
because i know some people will ask
quick comparison to the snyder cut while
there are some minor differences for my
purposes wonder woman versus the
terrorist is basically the exact same
thing it is interesting that steppenwolf
versus the amazon has him take down a
lot more and we see the hits more and it
is worth noting that pretty much every
time steppenwolf goes to attack someone
he one shots them and they're gone
similar to last time mara gets pinned to
the wall by the neck and thrown first
time steppenwolf takes on wonder woman
it's effectively the same as the
theatrical at least for my purposes
ditto for the league versus superman and
steppenwolf versus the league in the
climax again there are differences but
for the things i'm looking for it's
effectively the same fight aquaman
atlanta badasses the atlantis troops in
the opening mara later badasses the
atlantean guard the only reason she has
to flee is because they have guns she
does get grabbed by the neck at one
point but she tears off the guy's helmet
and that takes care of that and she gets
to badass a few guys during the big
climax but largely doesn't get involved
in the fight let's hop on over to the
x-men franchise first x-men movie
mystique badass is the senator
saber-tooth choke-lift storm she then
bowled him wolverine versus mystique
it's interesting that for most of that
fight she looks like him and during the
periods where she looks like herself she
actually doesn't really ever take a
proper hit toad takes on both gene and
storm and that's mostly made up of
tossing them around he does deliver two
kicks to storm who gets no hits in on
him initially although she does zap the
hell out of him later x2 during the
assault on the school all the female
students either get tranquilized or just
run we get to see mystique badass a
small group of guards taking no hits
gene dealing with a mind controlled
scott is just tossing him around
wolverine vs lady deathstrike pretty
evenly match because well they have the
same power set and that is again gonna
be a little bit of an asterisk we will
come back to it
x-men the last stand mystique is to
badass more guards in the interrogation
room presumably she does get restrained
after that but we don't see that we just
see her taking them on and while jean is
a major threat by the nature of her
power she is mostly either tossing
people around or just dissolving them
later on we have storm one shot and
quill i'm gonna count that as a badass
[Music]
when wolverine assaults magneto's camp
it's pretty much all dudes during the
melee portions of the alcatraz fight i
only saw dudes while the lady speedster
is paired off against storm kitty pride
takes no hits but that's also kind of
her entire skill set x-men first class
white queen tosses magneto off the boat
with one shot later on emma frost is
restrained by magneto and xavier it
isn't really a proper fight and angel
versus banshee and then havoc ending it
is a power throw around not really what
i'm looking for days of future pass
mystique is to badass a room of soldiers
again as well as the all the people in
the trask conference room she also
shoots and kicks around magneto a bit
this movie has an odd fixation with
having female characters get stabbed in
the back without really having much of a
fight it happens to storm and to blink
twice x-men apocalypse most of the
action scenes in this are just cgi power
slinging which is probably why this
movie is so boring or at least part of
it there is psylocke versus beast and
literally nobody lands a hit on anybody
until she throws him into a wall after
that she does get a legitimate kick in
the head and thrown but kurt bamf's
beast out of the fight before we can
really get a sense of how evenly matched
they are and of course mystique gets
choked up by apocalypse dark phoenix
again by the nature of her powers gene
is mostly just telekinetically throwing
people around including the fatal
tossing of mystique into some sharp wood
we do have a female character tossed out
of a train i'm gonna count that as one
shot as well as an unnamed female
villain who gets banffed out onto the
train tracks bryce dallas howard's
character vuk i think is her name she
basically just badasses and takes every
hit and it does not appear to slow her
down up until she takes on jean and then
it's just a cgi mess
new mutants really the only thing that
isn't a fight against some kind of
monster is reign doing a quick maul job
on the dock deadpool he tosses around
two unnamed women during the montage as
he hunts for francis it does kind of get
lampshaded this whole question that i'm
addressing this is confusing is it
sexist to hit you is it is it more
sexist to not hit you i mean the line
gets real
blurry we have the villain character of
angel dust who initially one shots
colossus she then takes a hit from
negasonic teenage warhead but they don't
really have a proper fight she gets the
one hit from her and then it's back to
her and colossus which is
a pretty legitimate brawl initially
colossus's hits don't seem to be doing
much sure but by the time the fight is
wrapping up yeah no that is a full-on
battle between them deadpool 2 again
kind of the nature of the beast with her
powers domino taking on the convoy
basically takes no hits when she takes
on cable she gets hits in and then he
chokeslams her she later gets to badass
some orderlies towards the end yukio and
negasonic do show up to take on
juggernaut but they basically just
deploy their powers one time each and
he's done so i'd consider that a badass
logan laura completely badasses the
soldiers she is only briefly restrained
by a harpoon and because of her healing
factor it does very little to slow her
down she gets to bad ass in the forest
again later and even pretty thoroughly
badasses x24 until he throws and gives
her a single backhand which i'm going to
count as a one shot because she doesn't
get involved in the fight after that
well she does but it's with a gun let's
take a quick rundown of some batman
movies batman returns catwoman badasses
some punks in the alley she disarms and
spooks the guards i'm gonna count it as
a badassing her first fight with batman
she just wails on him until he gets in
one backhand and then one more shot
later which basically one shots her off
the roof so she hits him a lot he hits
her twice and fights over batman and
robin ivy really only gets into a proper
fight against batgirl and batgirl is
briefly grabbed and choked by bane but
that's not really a fight the dark
knight rises slinging he gets to badass
guys in a bar and later the finance guy
in his bodyguards catwoman when she
first shows up in the bar nobody even
throws a punch at her when she
interrupts the robbery she just
completely badasses the three robbers
she has a relatively even fight against
sharon stone at the very end and let's
round it out with the blade movies
during the iconic first action scene
blade just one shots a bunch of vamps
which does include two women later on a
young vampire catches blade off guard
and gets in several kicks before going
down on a single backhand to the heads
there is a female vampire as part of a
duo taking on blade hand to hand she
gets in a couple completely ineffective
hits before getting knocked down and
blowed up karen knocks around a zombie
which granted is more down and dirty
than the usual badassing but he doesn't
get any hits in on her later on karen
takes on a female vampire who chokes her
and gives her a punch before karen maces
her blade's mom never lands a hit on him
during their brief confrontation he
chokes her and then stakes her blade 2
pretty even sword fight between blade
and nissa however there is going to be
an asterisk on this one
we're lumping it together at the end
we'll come back to it later on when she
runs into novak he simply restrains her
there isn't really a fight between them
blade trinity abigail badasses her way
through pretty much everything she does
technically take a couple of hits in her
introductory scene but that is when
she's faking helplessness so she
badasses the guys in the subway badasses
during the police escape badasses
security at the doctor's office badass
is a bunch of guards later takes on
three vampires badasses them she gets
briefly grabbed from behind but that
doesn't last long and it is worth noting
that during the climax while she's
badassing and not taking a single hit
the other two male characters have
parallel brawls going on where they are
both taking some notable hits and
towards the very end danica takes on
hannibal but it's interesting that we
never really see a hit in that one we
see people being tossed around we see
that she's clearly gotten the better of
hannibal but we don't really see the
fight okay so let's start actually
dissecting what i've thrown at you
now in case some of you are wondering
well isn't the badassing the hitting a
bunch of people and not taking any hits
yourself isn't that standard for an
action hero isn't that the case with a
lot of male heroes well
sometimes but usually by the climactic
fight they are going to take hits there
was a reason that a couple of points
along this road i did quick comparison
to the male fights going on in the same
movies as these movies where the female
characters are only being badasses and
it's the way in which these fights are
handled differently that i kind of want
to zero in on let's get into some
specifics as far as numbers go so out of
the 44 movies that i watched 16 of them
had women fighting women and out of
those 16 12 of them i considered to be
even matches so when women fought women
about three quarters of the time that
was an even fight out of those 44 movies
39 had women fighting men
however only eight of those fights i
considered to be even that is 21
21 versus 75
and for the record when women fought men
be at 101 or in a group 85 of the time
the women got to just badass them you
may have also noticed some recurring
trends and phrases when i talked about
the ways in which these fights went in
21 of these movies we had female
characters getting one-shotted i.e
taking a single hit thing going down
regardless of how the fight went prior
to that 29 had the major damage done to
female characters being they get thrown
and 39 featured either a chokehold or
some kind of restraint but otherwise not
a punch
so what is it that we're actually seeing
here well my original suspicion after
watching cobra kai season 3 that women
would only be paired off against women
and not allowed to fight guys at all
that definitely did not turn out to be
true the vast majority of these had
women fighting men
but
as noted it's not uneven footing
somebody is completely outmatching the
other either the female character
completely outmatches the masculine
characters and just badasses them
usually through never getting hit and if
a female character does take
quote-unquote hits
it's pretty common for it to be a throw
a choke something that isn't just a
punch
and even when punches happen there are
odd things that make it a little bit
weird and a little bit out of place i've
mentioned things like them happening way
in the distance in the background or
there's things like the sparring match
in captain marvel where it opens with
her getting punched in the face but we
don't see the punch we see the result of
it you slipped as a result of me
punching you in the face i was already
slipping when you happen to punch me in
the face the two events are not related
she takes one other punch later in that
sparring match but the sound design
makes it sound like a super soft hit
[Music]
by and large when women get a legitimate
punch
that's the end of the fight for them
they go down now again this was part of
why i wanted to look at superheroes i
thought that would be a way to avoid
this because it feels like everything is
built around this idea that women hit
faster but cannot take a punch it's like
they're working off 1980s and 90s arcade
brawler rules the female character is
always faster but cannot take nearly as
much damage now even with some of those
more or less even fights there's some
asterisks i mentioned let's deal with
those
now there's sort of a cluster of ones
where it is technically
a male versus female fight or a female
versus female fight but because of the
costume design the nature of the gender
is obscured so this applies to say the
first time ghost fights wasp and ant-man
now that is technically during the parts
where she is fighting scott a woman
versus man fight but she has not been
established as a woman yet similarly
with blade 2 when nissa and blade face
off now in both those cases if you are
paying careful attention to the costume
design you might notice a more feminine
build but the odds of you spotting that
your first time watching aren't great
and it's the same but in the other
direction with taskmaster in black widow
the first time that taskmaster takes on
black widow that's a pretty legit brawl
and taskmaster is designed in a way to
look like possibly a man and if you
manage to avoid all the online
speculation about who taskmaster would
be which pretty much everybody who was
speculating about it assumed it was
gonna be a woman but if you didn't know
that you could think she's taking on a
man but by the time the movie's over no
that wasn't the case so it's an even
footing fight that looks like a woman
versus man possibly but in fact is not
then there's some things that i marx's
fair fights that still need some kind of
asterisks i mentioned this in the black
panther so i mentioned the dorm milage
taking on killmonger and then later
shuri and nakia taking on killmonger now
in both these cases i would call them
pretty evenly matched however it is
worth noting that it is one guy versus
multiple women and the guy wins now that
is affected somewhat by the technology
having the black panther suit does tip
the balance significantly but i still
feel like that's worth mentioning and
honestly the kind of group scenarios get
weird and fuzzy in the first place
similarly with the enchantress versus
suicide squad i was surprised to see a
punch to the head delivered to her and
to see it clearly but she is still
outmatching an entire group and then you
have things like the fights in x2 or
with laura and logan where yeah they
take a few hits but they've also got a
healing factor which really feels like
it evens the playing field but even that
taken into consideration in logan laura
never really gets a direct hit she gets
speared once and one shotted by x-24 now
the lady deathstrike versus wolverine
fight in x2 that's pretty legit
initially she's more or less badassing
him and she definitely gets in more
shots than he does but he does get some
legit shots in on her but again they
both have healing factors so it almost
feels like
well they can do whatever they want
honestly out of the very few even
footing male versus female fights that i
found in these 44 films there were only
two that i would call clean matchups
that i do not feel the need to add
asterisks on to one was the first wonder
woman when she takes on the general
because while brief
that is actually a pretty evenly matched
fight and he does legit hit her the
other one being deadpool angel dust and
colossus by the end yeah that is a
proper brawl
so
what are we looking at here
we're looking at a situation where
there is a pretty decent amount of
female action heroes out there
but even in a genre where they should be
able to at least some of them be powered
up to the point to just have a flat out
even match
the presumption is still there that they
go down
with a single punch and there is a
reluctance to show a man punching a
woman thus we have the throws and the
chokes it's a way for a masculine
character to
assert a dominance in the fight without
having to actually punch a woman how
could you
i'm a woman so we're now living at a
time when there are more female action
heroes than ever before
but they seem to have a lot of really
strict prescriptions on how they are
allowed to be action heroes
they have to be ninjas they rarely take
a hit if they take a hit it hurts them a
lot more than the hits that they are
delivering against men
now how much of this is a built-in
assumption that women are just weaker
and will not take hits as well again
despite superpowers being in play or
whether it's some misguided sense of
chivalry where people just aren't
comfortable seeing a man punch a woman
there is cultural baggage it's a thing
and like every time i talk about tropes
and patterns this is not deliberate
there's no machiavellian council going
we cannot let women be shown to be
fighting on even footing with men
especially can't show that they can take
damage as well as dish it out no
that's not happening but the pattern's
still there and it's odd to me
because male action heroes can be
a lot of things they can be brawlers
they can be martial artists they can be
clumsy fighters they can be elegant
fighters they can be drunken masters but
most of all they can take a hit and keep
going it is one of the traits we really
ascribe to masculine heroes heck it was
the entire basis of the rocky franchise
but it ain't about how hard you hit it's
about how hard you can get hit and keep
moving forward how much you can take and
keep moving forward
that's how winning is done
take the hit and keep moving
but when it's a woman fighting don't get
hit at all because if you do you won't
get back up
if we were to step outside of the
superhero genre are there any notable
exceptions
my friends
charlize theron has entered the arena
mad max fury road the old guard and holy
crap atomic blonde when charlize thrawn
goes on to a fight against a guy this is
going to be an even footing blow for
blow fight and while pretty much all
those are more serious minded it can
happen in sillier things i noticed it in
gunpowder milkshake the women got hit
quite a bit heck if you want to go
further back the first mortal kombat
movie when kano took on sonia blade he
got to legit kick her in the gut and
then she killed him and while the
exceptions are wonderful
the fact that they're exceptions is
still weird to me and again
especially in something like the
superhero genre where powers should even
all this out even with the biggest
action genre that is dealing with more
and more and more female action heroines
every time a new movie comes out they're
still treated with kid gloves
oh they can dish it out oh they can take
you down
but they cannot stand up to punishment
and when they get hit if it doesn't take
them out usually it's because it has
literally zero impact on them or is in
some way deliberately softened be it
through sound design the hit being open
palm instead of a closed fist or more
often they get thrown or choked
but they don't get to fight
the way men get to fight kind of a shame
i think something that maybe would be a
good thing to work on
doing away with
again especially in superheroes
[Music]
so there you go folks that's my findings
and my thoughts
on how women are depicted in action
scenes in movies
focusing on the superhero genre but i
expect if you were to subdivide this and
do other genres you probably have
similar findings anyone who wants to do
that work feel free to reach out but i i
i'm done i've been working on this
forever what do you think about all this
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it like share and subscribe i got
a patreon that is how i pay my bills
it's how this whole operation stays up
and running any amount you're able to
support me does help me greatly you'll
notice i don't really get sponsors for
this channel i'm open to them i am for
sale but this exists because of your
help but if you're not able to that is
also okay
i'm not going to tell you what to do
because at the end of the day you are
the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey if you're sticking around through
the credits might as well hear some
names read out my patreon helps support
this and in particular i want to thank
raven mcbain bookworm mj tracy scrabbit
vincent paul bartolucci kailyn schwartz
edelin robin moore ross schultz shayla
gourlay wanna hear me mispronounce your
name check out the rewards on the
patreon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
oh
[Music]